>>> WE ARE VERY CLEAR THAT
RUSSIA SHOULD NOT INVADE THE
SOVEREIGNTY OF UKRAINE THAT WE
MUST STAND UP AND WE ARE
STANDING UP FOR ITS TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY.
WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR ALLIES
IN THAT REGARD AND VERY CLEAR
THAT WE ARE PREPARED TO ISSUE
SANCTIONS LIKE YOU'VE NOT SEEN
BEFORE.
>> VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS WITH A
WARNING TO RUSSIA OVER A
POTENTIAL INVASION OF UKRAINE.
THIS AS THE WORLD MARKS THE 30th
ANNIVERSARY OF THE SOVIET
UNION'S COLLAPSE AND RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN
CONTINUING TO GLORIFY THAT ERA.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH SUSAN
GLASSER.
GREAT TO SEE YOU.
SUSAN, ONE OF THE MYSTERIES OF
THIS SHIFT INSIDE RUSSIA IS THAT
MILLIONS OF RUSSIANS WERE KILLED
UNDER THE COMMUNIST REGIME
ESPECIALLY UNDER STALIN.
PUTIN SAID THE COLLAPSE WAS A
GREAT TRAGEDY AND BEEN BUMPING
UP THIS SOVIET NO, STALGIA.
WHAT DOES HE HOPE TO GAIN FROM
REVIVING THE GHOSTS OF THE OLD
SOVIET UNION?
>> THIS IS A CENTRAL THING TO
UNDERSTAND ABOUT VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S TWO-DECADE LEADERSHIP OF
RUSSIA IS THAT SOVIET NOSTALGIA
IS AT THE CORE OF HIS APPEAL AS
A POLITICIAN, A SENSE OF
GRIEVANCE.
HE WAS ALL ABOUT MAKING RUSSIA
GREAT AGAIN LONG BEFORE DONALD
TRUMP WAS TALKING ABOUT MAKING
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN BY LACKING
BACKWARDS.
BACK IN 2005 VLADIMIR PUTIN SAID
THE BREAKUP WAS THE GREATEST,
NOT JUST A GREAT TRAGEDY BUT THE
GREATEST GEOPOLITICAL
CATASTROPHE, NEVER MIND WORLD
WAR I.
HE CALLED IT AN HISTORICAL
TRAGEDY THIS WEEK AND ALL ABOUT
ESSENTIALLY TRYING TO REVISE AND
TO GET RID OF THE INTERNATIONAL
ORDER THAT WAS CONSTRUCTED ON
THE COLLAPSE OF THE SOVIET
UNION.
>> THAT CERTAINLY IS THE DANGER.
WE'RE JOINED BY ANN APPLEBAUM,
AN'S TEAMED AUTHOR OF BOOKS
DEMOCRACY RELATED.
WHAT DOES THIS IS A ABOUT HIS
BIGSS ON UKRAINE AND DO YOU
THINK THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION'S
PUSHBACK HAS BEEN STRONG ENOUGH
TO DETER HIM TO DATE?
>> SO TO BE VERY CLEAR AND TO
ECHO SUSAN, IT'S EXTREMELY
DANGEROUS THE LANGUAGE THAT HE
USES AND HE HAS BEEN USING IT
FOR SOME TIME BECAUSE OF COURSE
THERE'S NO LOGICAL REASON WHY
RUSSIA SHOULD INVADE UKRAINE.
UKRAINE DOES NOT THREATEN
RUSSIA.
NATO DOES NOT THREATEN RUSSIA.
NATO IS A DEFENSIVE ALLIANCE.
EVERYBODY WHO WORKS IN THE
RUSSIAN MILITARY KNOWS THAT THAT
SO PUTIN IS USING THE THREAT OF
THE PAST OF THE COLD WAR AS AN
EXCUSE TO PREPARE HIS PEOPLE FOR
INVASION OR ANOTHER SET OF GAMES
AROUND THAT.
FOR HIM THIS IS A JUSTIFICATION.
IT EXPLAINS BOTH WHY HE SHOULD
STILL BE PRESIDENT, HE'S
SOMEBODY WHO IS FAMOUSLY
CORRUPT, MOST OF THE POPULATION
KNOWS THAT.
HIS POPULARITY HAS BEEN
DECLINING RAPIDLY.
LIVING STANDARDS IN HIS COUNTRY
HAVE BEEN GOING DOWN SO WHY
SHOULD HE, BY WHAT LEGITIMACY
DOES HE REMAIN IN POWER AND HIS
ARGUMENT IS BECAUSE I'M THE ONE
WHO IS GOING TO PUT THE SOVIET
UNION BACK TOGETHER AGAIN AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S DANGEROUS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
DONE ONE VERY GOOD THING WHICH
IS THAT THEY BEGAN RAISING THE
ALARM ABOUT THIS PROBLEM OF THE
POTENTIAL FOR A RUSSIAN INVASION
OF UKRAINE SEVERAL WEEKS AGO AND
THEY HAVE ALARMED EUROPEAN
ALLIES, THEY HAVE PEOPLE AWARE
OF WHAT'S GOING ON, PEOPLE IN
UKRAINE AWARE, THEY SEEM TO HAVE
A LOT OF INTELLIGENCE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON AND THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT.
OF COURSE WHAT WE HAVE NOT DONE
AND THIS IS NOT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION'S FAULT BUT IT
GOES BACK EIGHT YEARS NOW,
CERTAINLY TO THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WHICH PLAYED ALL
KINDS OF GAMES WITH AS YOU WILL
REMEMBER WITH UKRAINIAN MILITARY
AID, WE HAVE NOT MADE AN
ENORMOUS EFFORT TO MILITARIZE
UKRAINE TO SUPPORT UKRAINE IN A
CERTAIN WAY THAT IT WOULD MAKE
THE IDEA OF INVASION IMPOSSIBLE
OR UNTHINKABLE AND THAT'S THE
MISTAKE THE U.S. AND OTHERS IN
EUROPE HAVE MADE GOING BACK
NEARLY A DECADE NOW.
>> SUSAN, THAT GETS TO WHAT WENT
WRONG IN THE 30 YEARS SINCE THE
COLLAPSE OF THE SOVIET UNION.
YOU'RE COAUTHOR OF AN EXCELLENT
BOOK ON JAMES BAKER WITH YOUR
HUSBAND.
I WONDER IN YOUR RESEARCH AND
INTERVIEWS, WHAT BAKER FEELS
WENT WRONG, WHAT YOU BELIEVE
WENT WRONG WHERE WE LOST THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND INSTEAD OF
FALLING BACK TOMENT SO OF THE
COLD WAR DIVIDES AND RHETORIC.
>> WELL, I THINK BAKER, THE
FORMER SECRETARY OF STATE AT THE
TIME OF THE COLLAPSE OF THE
SOVIET UNION HIS ARGUMENT WOULD
BE A LOT WENT RIGHT IN THE SENSE
IT WAS A LARGELY PEACEFUL AND
EMPIRES COLLAPSING IS PROBABLY
ONE OF THE MOST DANGEROUS
GEOPOLITICAL MOMENTS, WARS OF
MANY DIFFERENT VARIETIES WERE A
POSSIBILITY AT THAT TIME, A FEW
DID BREAK OUT AND I THINK THE
IMPERATIVE OF THE UNITED STATES
AT THAT TIME UNDER GEORGE H.W.
BUSH AND BAKER WAS TO HIT AS
SOFT OF A LANDING AS POSSIBLE TO
ENSURE THERE WASN'T A CATACLYSM
THAT RESULTED FROM THIS
INCREDIBLE MOMENT OF INSTABILITY
IN THE WORLD ORDER.
THEY ESSENTIALLY PATCHED
TOGETHER THE POST WORLD WAR II
INSTITUTIONS FOR A NEW ERA AND
WE'VE SEEN THE UNRAVELING OF
THAT LARGELY AIDED AND ABETTED
BY VLADIMIR PUTIN.
PUTIN IS IN A MUCH STRONGER
POSITION THAN HE WAS TWO DECADES
AGO WHEN HE CAME INTO POWER IN
THE SENSE REBUILT THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY AND IT'S NOT
THEORETICAL THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT CAN VLADIMIR PUTIN INVADE
UKRAINE BECAUSE HE ALREADY DID
SO IN 2014.
WHAT'S STRIKING TO ME IS THE
NEED HE HAS FELT TO MANUFACTURE
THIS CRISIS.
I JUST CAN'T UNDERSCORE THAT
ENOUGH.
THERE IS NO IMMINENT THREAT OF
NATO EXPANDING INTO UKRAINE AS
HE CLAIMS.
UKRAINE IS NOT ANY CLOSER REALLY
TO JOINING NATO TODAY THAN IT
WAS IN 2014, WHEN PUTIN INVADED
IT THE FIRST TIME AND TOOK OVER
THE CRIMEAN PENINSULA.
SO THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT POINT
FOR PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND.
>> IT IS, AND I WISH WE COULD
KEEP TALKING ABOUT THIS.
ANNE, YOU'VE WRITTEN ABOUT T